people who've been fed a lot of this
hate about Muslims and if you go to a
predominantly Muslim country and you're
not yet Muslim and I'm Muslim that you
can get your head chopped off you're
gonna all sorts of evil is gonna happen
to you do what many have done visit a
predominantly Muslim country and see how
you're treated I mean talk to people get
out of your comfort zone get out of your
village and travel this is another way
to eradicate some of this anti-islamism
this anti-muslim fear that many people
have if you can't leave your city uh
visit Hamas visit some Muslims if you
enjoyed this short clip visit the dean
show TV on YouTube to watch the full
video